Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How are you doing?
I'm doing great.
What were you doing before I called you?
I just came back home.
Did you go somewhere?
I went shopping with my brother.
Did you buy anything for yourself?
Yes, I did.
I bought some clothes.
What kind of clothes did you buy?
I bought a jacket, a pair of blue jeans, a skirt and a red t-shirt.
Wow.
That's a lot.
You must be rich!
Not really.
They were having a big sale.
What about your brother?
Did he buy anything?
Yes.
He bought a baseball cap, a belt, and sneakers.
I guess you guys like to dress down, don't you?
Well, I do, but I'm not so sure about my brother.
Does he like to dress up?
Yes, and he looks good in a suit, indeed.
Oh, I want to see him.